this is jaco podcast number 89 with echo
Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening I was sitting
in my Tactical Operations Center in
Ramadi alone I was staring at a document
on my computer and I had to keep wiping
tears from my face as I read it the
document had been submitted to me by the
Delta platoon commander there was an
award recommendation for Michael Monsoor
and the award was the Medal of Honor for
Mikey he had been sitting on an
outcropping of a roof in South Ramadi on
an overwatch and a grenade which had
been thrown from an unseen location
actually hit him in the chest and fell
to the ground in front of him and he
could have jumped away from the grenade
and he could have saved himself but if
he had done that his teammates that were
positioned next to him they would have
been exposed to that blast so instead of
moving away from the grenade
Mikey jumped on the grenade he smothered
it and he absorbed its lethal explosion
thereby saving our teammates and at the
same time
sacrificing his own life
the morning that had happened September
29th 2006 I got a call from the
battalion commander from the first to
the 506 an outstanding officer and
leader that I respected and admired and
this element from Delta platoon had been
in the field receiving fire and
returning fire most in the morning which
was nothing new or nothing unusual but
it had escalated and I knew that there
had been trouble and when the colonel
called me he told me that there had been
a bad fight and then he went down the
list of my men describing quickly what
their wounds were and what their status
was and and pretty much telling me that
they were gonna be okay until he got to
Mikey and I could hear a shift in his
voice it became very grave and very
serious and I could hear the the
sympathy in it and I knew what was
coming
Mikey got hit bad he got hit really bad
Jocko
and I don't think he's gonna make it and
my heart jumped through my chest and
then it sank back down to my stomach and
then erupted into my brain in a
maddening rush of anger and horror and
gut-wrenching sadness and I grabbed all
that insanity and all that emotion and I
pulled it back into my mind and I held
it down there while I uttered the only
words that I could muster Roger that sir
and when the delta platoon commander
who's one of my best friends and a very
close friend of Mikey's when he called
me we were mechanical we had work to do
he debriefed me
I listened we discussed the follow-up
and the next steps and the resupply and
the operational impact of the casualties
we held it together
and the next day I talked to one of the
seal officers that Mikey had saved I
talked to him on the phone because he
was in Germany already with the other
seal that had been wounded badly on the
rooftop both of whom would have been
dead if it hadn't been for Mikey they
were only wounded and because of that
they were heading home and when I talked
to this young officer he explained to me
what happened with perfect clarity Mikey
could have jumped away and saved himself
but he did not his only movement was
toward the grenade Mikey did not
hesitate
what kind of a man does that and when I
was a brand new guy at SEAL team 1 I
began to learn and understand what kind
of man did that you see as a young
enlisted seal at SEAL team one there
were two pictures on the quarterdeck
just to the pictures were of SEAL team
ones Medal of Honor recipients
lieutenant Bob Kerrey and petty officer
2nd class Mike Thornton and we young
guys we memorized their names as well as
the name of the SEAL team two Medal of
Honor recipient lieutenant Tom Norris
[Music]
and we read their citations over and
over again and debrief them amongst
ourselves but we young enlisted seals we
focused on on Mike Thornton he was an
enlisted man like we were and we hadn't
heard about him and he was a legend not
only for his actions but for his
reputation as a seal as an operator as a
leader as an all-around badass frogman
that we all aspired to be as a young
enlisted SEAL he was the mark he was the
example he was Mike Thornton
and a few months after checking into
SEAL team one I was in Virginia Beach I
was going to a school at the Navy base
there on Little Creek and one day after
work we went to a place called Papa's
pub don't mind you I wasn't even old
enough to get in but the chief snuck me
in there
and as we were sitting there having some
food and talking a handful of other
seals walked in and and they were
wearing their full dress choker whites
and one of them was a big monster of a
man and he had a rack of ribbons up to
his shoulder and the Medal of Honor
around his neck and I knew exactly who
it was it was Mike Thornton right there
in front of me the ultimate seal the
ultimate hero standing there in the
flesh then my chief looked and he he saw
how awestruck I was and he told me to go
over there and say hi
which I did now again I was a new guy I
didn't have my Trident yet
and at SEAL team one at the time as I
have accounted over and over again we
knew guys pretty much got treated like
worthless scum but when I introduced
myself to Mike Thornton slap me on the
back and said welcome to the teams and
then he told me I'm from Team one - I'm
from Team one - and then he bought me
beer and treated me like I was his
brother the man himself treating a
pathetic new guy like me like I was one
of his long-lost buddies and I never
forgot that attitude and that humility
and I would see Mike Thornton
occasionally over the years and I and I
swear it always seemed like he
remembered me at least in my mind but
years later he actually did get to know
me a little bit when Mike Eamon Soares
parents received the Medal of Honor from
President Bush in the White House I was
with Mike Thornton again and after that
solemn ceremony well we went and we
drank and we raised hell and we raised
our glasses to mikey into the rest of
our fallen brothers and mike Fortin
treated me and the rest of our task unit
the same way he treated me when I first
met him like we were all brothers and
that night now that I had seen combat
myself and seen with my own eyes the
bravery and the selflessness and the
sacrifice that is the very core of our
community I finally understood why Mike
Thornton treated us all like brothers
it's because we were and we are
[Music]
and with that it is an absolute honor to
have here tonight a hero a legend a
patriot and someone I'm so proud to be
able to call brother retired seal and
Medal of Honor recipient Mike Thornton
sir welcome aboard
thanks Chacos think so and it's my honor
to be here too
you are unbelievable warrior as Mikey
Mansour I tell you my love goes up to
George and Sally and everybody there but
that was an unbelievable day to have
Tommy and me there in Colin and in a pod
Senath and all the other team mates
there it was a lot different than when I
received my Mountain so but it he was an
honor that these young men are getting
the respect that they deserve so much
and then to bring the whole team home
when I received my medal was only Tommy
Tommy received his knows only me so god
bless the Navy they're finally getting
it right and honoring these great young
men like Mikey Mansour and Edie Byers so
you recently had a book come out which
is awesome and you wrote it with your
fellow teammate and and fellow Medal of
Honor winner Tom Norris and also with
another seal dick couch and and the book
is called by honor bound and you know
for me you know I was talking about this
before the podcast before we started
recording you even though you want to
know they get these really good debriefs
in the SEAL Teams and you'd think that
there was a vault with all these great
debriefs and that you explained to you
everything that happened on certain
missions especially highly important
missions you think that that existed but
it actually doesn't exist
and for me this book was like the the
detailed debrief that I always wanted to
have you know not only of the operation
that you did with Tommy but also the one
that Tommy conducted by himself and and
both of them are just so well detailed
in here and it's just a phenomenal book
to get that kind of granular detail of
what you lived through that like I said
even being in the SEAL Teams myself for
20 years I never had as good of an
understanding at all as I have these
operations now so thank you for writing
it and you know I want to dive into it a
little bit because that's kind of what I
do on this podcast is definitely this
pleasure yeah and and so it's you know I
had to jump around a little bit but just
what talking about your background and
where you came from growing up in in
South Carolina yeah correct I was born
and raised in the hills of South
Carolina and my my father was my hero of
all times you only had a sixth grade
education and my dad was in the
Philippines from 39 and he got left in
the Philippines after MacArthur pulled
out and he was one of the Raiders over
there they did a movie and I see I only
had a sixth grade education but he was
the guy that everybody respected he had
his own company and I used to ask guys
why you've been working for my father
for 30 years you know he said because he
and my dad always told me this and
that's what I tried to do when I was in
the team to take care of your people
your people will take care of you and my
mother gave us love and religion and and
but daddy was hard as rocks and but he
had the greatest respect for that man
and everybody else that knew my father
had the same respect for him now you
mentioned that your dad you know had a
sixth education obviously he was he was
a hero to you and a successful guy and
was able to put things together in his
life and well did he ever talk about
what he did in the pie not until I had
been wounded several times and during my
second tour overseas and he said he said
I think you'll understand this and I
said
I understood the first time I was ever
wounded so you know wounded in 1939 or
wounded in 1969 or wounded in in today's
war I think it brings a reality that war
sucks any way you look at it yeah
there's no doubt about that I guess your
dad wanted you to earn being able to
hear good stories from him but you got
to get wounded before I'm going to tell
you that fair more than once
that's a hard man now I'm going to the
book a little bit this is you talking I
didn't do that well in school I couldn't
read and I still have problems with it
I'm Dyslexic back then they didn't call
it that you were just dumb for me it
meant that I simply couldn't keep up in
school I did okay in math but that was
probably the only thing I loved history
otherwise I did poorly I had to repeat
my sophomore year in high school and
that really hurt my pride so it's no
wonder I got in with the wrong crowd and
started getting into trouble nothing
serious but we were mischievous southern
country boys drinking beer and making
bad decisions
the sheriff was out to the house a few
times and there were was a time or two
in juvenile court and I caught a lot of
classes I had 72 absences in my senior
year in high school that's it that's it
pretty pretty pretty legit record well
you could only miss 30 and he
automatically failed but I didn't think
they wanted to see me coming back so you
know to that dyslexia and thank God we
found out what he really is and actually
I've never even read the book my wife's
read it to me five times and I'd make
the changes and stuff like that but I do
have it on tape and if I hear something
I understand it but what I'm trying to
say in that is it's like young men know
you may have it tough but you can redo
this I've been a successful businessman
I want to always do the ranks and I got
a commission and I did this and I'm just
trying to say there's only one and
that's what I tell these kids when
they're going through training but you
know
that I was only one person school stop
you and I sure so there's always to get
across that obstacle under it around it
on top of it in one way the other so
don't let something stop you and and for
you to move forward and make a better
life for yourself in your family
awesome awesome words right there now
speaking of moving forward it's is you
had like the classic case of the judge
telling you alright son
you can either join the Navy or we're
gonna find a place that you're not gonna
like so much as home well I didn't know
this 20 years later my father finally
tell me him in the juvenile judge was a
there were friends with each other and
he said I don't let you make your first
major decision go to juvenile basically
six months and you know juvenile hall or
I could turn around and make the first
major decision in my life and I didn't
saw that crazy movie the five Solomon
brothers during World War two then I saw
the movie the navy frogmen with Richard
Widmark and I turned around I said I've
always wanted to be a UDT frogman and I
saluted and a guide the guy that
enlisted me was a second class
machinists mate and Ned his name was Ned
Johnson and when he retired he was back
as an 89 he was a senior enlisted for
recruiting the state of South Carolina
and he tells everybody I he'd made Mike
Thornton who he was today at doubts then
so you come in and did you you just went
boot camp and then straight to buds or
you guys did have buds you guys called
it on a fiancee a knee replacement
underdog underwater demolition recruit
training I was supposed to go and I was
trying to go straight from there they
said no we and you have to go to outside
I like I saved my dyslexia was pretty
bad and I had to get a 10-point waiver
just to get into the teams and they must
have needed people pretty damn bad
because I finally got my ways when I was
in Hawaii and I
I came back to Coronado went through
training and I was thinking about you
know going through training you know
here's here's a quote from you coming
through training we had some instructors
who were not only good teachers but they
were real characters there was Vince
Oliveira who is part American Indian and
a plank holder at SEAL team one he
called us palefaces
and we stood an on fear of instructor
oliviere then there was Dick Allen a
black seal who was the navy boxing
champion he once sparred with Muhammad
Ali when Ali was asked once who hit him
the hardest he said it was a chief petty
officer in the in the u.s. navy named
dick Allen and then there was instructor
Terry Moy who we called mother Moy it
seemed as if he was always watching us
making sure everything we did was that
we put out a hundred percent so what I
was thinking about during this was when
I went through I went through in 1991
and there was clearly there were some
rules in place but also the instructors
kind of did what they wanted to and then
what the command wasn't watching them
there's clearly there's more rules and
oversight now I've seen that with my own
eyes but I can't even imagine what it
was like when you were going through
them but the instructors must have just
been able to do whatever the hell they
wanted to do to you guys I tell you
offense Oliveira the most sadistic son
of a [ __ ] ever met in my life okay yeah
and I was just with Terry Moore the last
two days of course this is reunion
weekend right Terry still looks like a
gladiator as he did back then and Dick
Allen used to hang us from the Fulop bar
and he'd punch us in the stomach but I
tell you if you didn't keep her hands
loose I mean if you didn't keep your
hands loose he'd kill him then of course
dick and Vince and dick both have passed
and but they're their memories and
there's a funny thing about life itself
you know and it's not what you've done
this the respect you want to gain from
the teammates and dick and Terry and
Vince all-grain game my respect and my
love and
they'll all of as long as might thorns
alive the stories will continue going
off that's what I was that's all I want
from the the my peers to remember who
Mike Thornton is us and that's and
that's what those guys taught me yeah
were those guys one of those guys
Vietnam vets or were they Korean War
vets both a little bit of everything
Vietnam vets then there was Tommy
hatchet in there too they used to call
Tommy and I after I got in the team's of
salt and pepper he's a great big old
black guy and those stronger than damn
hawks and you know actually Vince was
one of the original seals in 1962 and he
went over to Nam of course back then
they didn't know what they would do with
the seals they're not a period of time
so you get uh you get done with buds and
I'm going to the book here there were 22
guys who graduated in my class 18 from
the original 129 I remember how lucky
and proud I felt as I was given orders
to SEAL team one even back then it was
no small thing being a Navy SEAL but
it's one thing to be a seal and yet
another to do the work of a seal I
thought that was an important little
highlight there of like when you get
done with buds it's just the beginning
really correct is just you just cracked
open the door then you got to go through
the damn door and have to get through
the door you got to prove yourself and
like like you're saying we're a nobody
back then you know if you hadn't had a
couple of tours of Vietnam you were just
trashes or savory sure yeah so going the
book my first platoon was Charlie
platoon we were in country from 1969
through or from December 1969 through
July 1970 we worked out of a place
called dong Island and it was a great
deployment we had solid platoon officers
and our platoon petia leading petty
officer was Barry Enoch one of the
finest steel operators a team won when I
made my first deployment
he was my see daddy it was the same for
all of us on our first combat tour and
it was an active tour seems like every
other night we'd be out most of the time
we made contact I remember we took down
a few province-level Vietcong
Drey types and one time we had a good
intelligence we were able to take down
an entire VC grenade factory it was
great so that was your first appointment
when you talk about Barry Barry Enoch
and actually how KooKoo Dahl talks about
as well as says us as new guys even the
veterans we worshiped Barry Enoch he was
a great leader and a great teacher what
was it about him that made him just that
made you guys remember him and revere
him so much well I think it's like you
were talking about me in your gradient
reduction which I don't deserve that but
uh Barry was a leader he took care
everybody and he's a guy he kind of like
I looked up to my father he was my see
daddy and he was always there for all of
us and me and last night tomboy Hannah
and me and Wayne Hampton and Mike
lacrosse and and how Kuykendall were all
getting a picture together and then
remembering the great guys and we were
all we're talking about Barry of course
Barry felt passed away a few years ago
and he's another guy you know it's like
I say he'll always be in all our
conversations and was somebody we all
looked up to you know so it's the great
leadership I mean that he showed us and
and not just the leadership as a leader
but the leadership he showed us to try
to be a better person
and and that deployment what were you
guys doing you guys were doing we guys
two point off of boats were you guys
going in helicopters you guys going on
foot patrols a little bit everything a
little bit of everything foot patrols
basically Sam pans Whalers by that time
we finally got the LSS C's which were in
the light and then the medium support
SEAL support craft of course we had the
mighty moe a lot of our stuff was the
mighty moe oh it was a Mike Big Mike
Hayden had the you see it had all the
the rebar by about 20 inches out so if
he got hit by an RPG it explode there
instead of going through the hole we did
a lot of like I was working down that
down the sea float was steve frist with
the kcs his scopes back then we didn't
have that many sill so we would help
each other we did if they say we need
help
converse our people all right around and
dead Tom would send the guys at and he
felt should be going so we'd like Rich
Solano myself and much other guys would
go out and help other platoons and stuff
and we you a 60 gunner I was a 60 out of
stoner 60 and I and I carried a car 15
but always carry the Swedish Kate with
me all the time and a pistol always had
a backup backup in the back of your neck
go back over there so you know some we
have funny things you know and you and
you learn from each other so it's like
that uh that uh when we hit that a
grenade factory Mikey sands jumped out
and he had a sixteen is he didn't lock
down he didn't lock down as uh as hitch
and his his he jumped out of the boat
his barrel fell out in the water and the
river and he's definitely diction he's
yelling give me one of your guns I said
hell no I'm keeping all my guns here so
you know as we all learned and Mike was
a great m60 guy he saved our asses many
times and but um everybody did their and
did their job is just as you were saying
long it was a team effort and my life
was saved by people I might look oz and
other people in our platoon and and we
backed each other up all the time and
and that was a super-active
actually how how Kuykendall it was
talking about you here in the book this
is Hal talkin I can remember more than
one firefight where we were shooting and
ducking sometimes more ducking than
shooting but Mike would be right there
working that sixty with a big grin on
his face there were plenty of times when
I was really scared but I'm not sure
Mike ever was he was reliable and brave
but I'm not sure he ever knew or
understood fear like the rest of us he
was a great teammate and my god he was
strong none of us could believe how much
ammo he carried sometimes he'd go out
with a thousand rounds or more that's
close to 80 pounds of just ammo and he'd
swim canals with that load
he'd just shrug and say you don't want
your 60 gunner to run out of ammo do you
we got through a pretty active
deployment with no one getting killed
then a couple of guys stayed behind to
break in the new platoon while the rest
of us packed up and left they were two
of our best and one of them was killed
in a helo crash with three other seals
we took it hard when Rich Solano was
killed but I think Mike took it the
hardest
Mike was a guy who really cared for his
teammates so so even with all that
action you guys you guys went through
the deployment with you know what did
you take a few wounded guys but you only
had a few but nobody was killed and
actually we were I was down at Sea float
and rich Solano was working with the
Gulf platoon I thinking and that was
when the helicopter went down and of
course when you come off a hot LZ you're
supposed to shut down your aircraft and
check the rotor blades because back then
the rotor blades could have a hole and
it could last for 30 minutes or 45 or an
hour and the pilot of the helo when we
get back for a birthday party or
something and the helo fountain and
actually rich was killed and Berlin was
killed and Toby Thomas was killed
Gardner was killed so that was one of
our base we lost five guys that day not
for we lost five and I went down and and
identified the bodies and it was you
know I've only had one bad dream in my
whole life and it was after identifying
that because rich whole face was
completely gone and only way I could
identify me he had a scar on his arm and
but you know a loss of any teammate as
you know as well as I do that like Mikey
and and every time you know every time I
lose it even a new kid today which I've
been out speaking to their classes and
stuff like that you lose a little bit
more your heart I don't know how much
more of my heart I got to lose but it
takes it out of you
I mean it is I don't want to see anybody
ever get hurt or especially a loss of a
loved one and they're all there the
their lifes are just as important to me
with the new kids today as rich and all
those guys were important to me back
then you you come home from that
deployment and you go into SEAL team one
cadre which we actually have talked
about on here with Roger Hayden because
we still we when I was a at SEAL team
one and I was in training cell we still
called the cadre and that was I don't
know 20 something years later and I
never even made the connection and and
Roger and I talked about the fact that
you know some of the training that you
guys implemented back there the the the
point man course where you're walking
through and the trip wires are there and
all that we still did that a lot of the
demo we still did and and so that's what
that's what you did when you got home
you went into that training cell being
cadre and teaching and you know you
mention here that you learned a lot
being an instructor and I always I
always agree with that in fact when when
I was in the SEAL Teams no one wanted to
go to the training department right we
all wanted to just deploy just employ
deploy so when I took over the training
I always told guys look if you want to
be you know if you want to master what
you do you got to go and teach it and
you also mention al Huey in here and
when I went through buds when we are at
San Clemente Island every night when the
Sun Goes Down we'd sing the song good
night al Huey good night out Huey good
night out Huey wherever you may be and I
never knew and still don't know who al
Huey is other than the campus called al
Hugh it's called camp al Huey out there
and and honestly I make my kids sing
this song when Sun Goes Down my me and
my kids we sing this song I'm sure
you've heard of Dave Shively Commodores
Shively and Allen and Daver
best of friends and Al was another
mentor like Barry not to me
and they went through class two of UDT
back in the 50s and there were all in
Korea and stuff and he led by example
again you know but I mean it's kind of
like when he talks it better be like EF
Hutton you better be listening keeping
your ears wide open and just as I'll
tell me one day he says you know good
Lord gave you one mouth two ears and two
eyes so use 80% of that and pick the
other ones shut for 20% and then you you
from cadre you had a chance you went
back and deployed again but you went to
Thailand and we gonna teaching the Thai
SEALs we took trained the Thai seals I
was along with dick Flanagan and one of
the finest officers as tomboy hen was a
great officer great leader and Al was
with us on that nest reason Hawaii owl
and I were so close and we trained the
Thai UDT and the SEAL team Texas and
then they went up and they worked off
the borders all I can say about that
yeah and understood and then you got
home from that and now it looked like
the war in Vietnam was kind of winding
down and there weren't full seal
opportunist deploying any more no more
Silpat UN's only basically what we were
going over we were sending enlisted LDN
advisers and like a bunch of the guys
that know were over there with me on
that tour was uh it was at the reunion
and it was kind of funny to get together
and talk with all of them you know and
talk about but we've lost a lot of those
guys which have passed in to age or
cancer or something and you know it's
just one girth in about the reunion you
know none of us are getting any damn
younger so you better get out and see
your shipmates anytime you get a chance
oh yeah the LD NN you mentioned and just
that everyone knows with that that those
are like Vietnamese South Vietnamese
seals seals and the LD instance for a
living and die as what is actually in
Vietnamese does that mean like a warrior
from the Sears on the Bay Area's just
type me up so you get a chance to go
back again and this is funny cuz
typical seal you know it's like oh we
need to go back on deployment again yes
I'll go he said me I'm going back to the
book so when I got to Vietnam this time
I spent close to a week at NHA trang
working with the LD n ends there getting
a feel for the what they were doing in
the field I'd work with the Vietnamese
seals on my first tour back in 1969 US
and I saw a few familiar faces you have
to hand it to those guys for them there
were no combat rotations life was combat
24/7 year in year out
they fought until they were killed or as
it worked out in the end we lost the war
so those are the guys you're working
with and I think it's I mean you get
into the relationship that you formed
with these guys which was you know they
were other brothers yep they were that
you took care of them they took care of
you and of course the reason a nice to
feel that Tommy and I are still alive
today is cause a day nanquan which I
explained in the book they were I'd
worked with him on previous chores and
many operations and they were there
there's just like one of us I mean they
took care of me so that's the reason I
hand-picked those two guys that was dang
and Quang Quang those those were guys
that you had worked with before
Vietnamese seals and so you get to to
lean on am I saying that right to an
unasked wound on okay so you get to
tubing on this is where you're gonna be
working out of and again you're not the
seal platoon this is a totally different
situation and what you had there into
Enon if I gathered it all correctly you
had five enlisted seals from SEAL team
one and then you had to seal team two
officers and then pause with those two
seal team two officers who were sound
like they were more junior guys maybe it
was their first deployment but then
Tommy Norris showed up as well as the
OSE yeah
Shively captain shot come north Chablis
he had all the seals du/dt EOD divers
everybody and then Tommy Nelson was our
Lieutenant Commander no three and he was
the head of all the sills Tommy was the
senior sill operator in country then we
had Ryan mccumbee and another lieutenant
it was there then they were all they
were all East Coast guys now we had
actually I think we had more like 18
enlisted guy okay and we and we broke it
up and Gary Gary Chamberlain and Harry
Connick OA went with lieutenant Hughes
down one thing then Ryan mccumbee was
our boss and I stayed up so everybody it
had many tours that went down south and
I had the most tours and I stayed up
north with Ryan McCombie then Tommy
would go back and forth to run
operations of course it was hard to get
a OS approved because uh you know it was
pretty at that time we were fighting in
quandary and way city and all that stuff
and they were trying to overtake it but
we're still were able to get our ops in
and you had what two squads of LDN and
what made up a squad of LD NN
approximately I think we had we had more
LDN ends than we did but we separated
those guys too
I know when we went on the operation
woody was we always had a cell as you
know on an insertion extraction craft
and would he had a we only had three ill
names on the OP with us but he had
another six or eight on her on the boat
the boat if we needed supplies so it and
and I gotta mention this because again
it's half the book of by honorbound is
we've been throwing Tommy Norris his
name around here and when he showed up
to work with you guys he had been in
country for some period of time and he
had done this this multiple pilot rescue
operations the bat 21 mission and Tommy
was
say that I knew about his reputation and
he knew about my reputation and it was
kind of funny timing I only operated one
time and that was that operation but we
were of course still best of friends and
I know when we resubmitted tommy was put
in for a medal and it was resubmitted
and then he was upgraded to the Medal of
Honor later on and greatest friend any
man could ever ask for and I look back
on the officers and the leadership we
had on like I was saying tomboy Hannah
and Captain Shively and and Tommy and
and Ryan mccumbee and and norm Carly and
I'm you know even when we were in sixth
with more sinkhole and stuff like that
it was we had some great leaders you
know and all those guys took care of
their people that's what I really looked
up to them for for always being there
for the troops you know they make you
your ass up but nobody else is going to
so now once Tommy shows up they you get
to start getting the mission tasking for
this mission that becomes you know the
mission and the Paris peace talks were
going on but you know tom tom was saying
that there's no at the operational level
you guys like oh that's great but it's
not changing anything for us on the
ground meanwhile they're you know
they're they're attacking way city and
it's just hard and so Tom goes down he
gets called down by by the Commodore
Shively Shively to to get a mission
tasking and this is this is Tom Norris
talking
Uncle Dave had me take a seat in his
office that's what that's what you guys
called the Commodore yeah I never called
any my Commodores an uncle at least not
to their faces
Uncle Dave had me take a seat in his
office and I could tell he had something
on his mind Tom he said the Vietnamese
commander of the LD NN wants to run a
seal reconnaissance mission to the mouth
of the country Quang Viet River is that
right quadtree Quan tree river
specifically he and his superiors won
to know about the defense's an enemy
disposition around Quan tree Naval Base
and he wants a Vietnamese LDN an officer
to head up the reconnaissance team I
want you to run the operation to ensure
the mission gets done properly but this
needs to be seen as a Vietnamese
operation so that was the tasking doing
doing a reconnaissance correct pretty
normal operation I'm it's pretty
standard it sounds like you guys were
running those type of operations fairly
regularly yeah basically the NVA had
already moved across the quad via River
so that was a new we knew that and we
knew and they were trying to take over
quandary again and and they attacked
onwe city that was an April and this was
an October and when this thing was going
down so we knew was hot and heavy up
there but tommy said yes you know you
never said no to Uncle Dave and and so
you guys decide her or Tom you know
let's you know hey let's do a small a
small group you're gonna take five guys
for two Americans and three Vietnamese
seals right obviously the two are you
and and Tom Norris and then the three
the three guys that you're going to take
with you the three Vietnamese that
you're going to take with you two of
them were your hand-selected guys Quan
Quan and then there was another officer
the other guy was an officer right
correct and he was lieutenant I've heard
you tell the story in here
he's called lieutenant Tuan yeah we got
a always called Thai well yeah but we
put a different name in there because uh
he kind of made the operation Co South
got got it
so here's the basic concept of
operations so I was really the funny
part of it
Tommy said I'll do the mission if you
let me choose who I want to take photos
back then we had a rotation basically
where everybody get a chance to go in
the fill and with I always went in the
field with the new guys and stuff and
and he said I'd like to make a choice in
Uncle Dave said well [ __ ] I know it is
and he said well we've never operated
together and he saw bet just Mike
Thornton and he said yes sir that's who
I want to take with me on
operation and actually woody was
supposed to be going in on that
operation and but we took woody on the
insertion extraction means of
transportation and that's that's that's
bill Woodruff Woodruff who you talking
about yeah and we will get into what his
role was here's the here's the overview
of the mission and this is this is Tom
Norris talking it was not a particularly
difficult mission and it was certainly
something we'd done before so we knew
the drill in general is about a 50-mile
transit from two Enon up the cuvette
river in our boats with a max speed of
about eight knots that was a little more
than six hours so you're talking about a
six hour transit the plan was to get
well out to sea so no one on the beach
could know which direction we were
heading north or south once we turned in
this case north we'd make our way up the
coast then turn west back into shore
then we hope to be on station off the
southern bank of the Ku Yvette River
soon as possible after dark we'd then
leave the junks and paddle in close to
shore on rubber boats and then swim the
last swim ashore from the rubber boats
we'd insert do our job and get out
before first light we didn't have to be
back at two Enon before first light but
we sure as heck wanted to be back across
the beach and away from the coast before
sunup I was told I'd have offshore Navy
support in the way of two destroyers so
if we're running a little late in
getting out of there I'd have some
friendly on-call fire support so that's
a real standard mission that you know
when I first got the team one we did
that not not the exact same thing and
not real but we trained it all the time
you're gonna get on you know mark fives
and you're gonna have your zodiacs on
there then you're gonna get a little
closer to the beach and once you get
close to the beach to drop off the
zodiacs then you get a little bit close
to the beach and then the last thing you
do is get out the boats swim in you go
do your operation so kind of standard
stuff and you know he says it's not
something you hadn't done before it's
correct
here's what you were talking about with
when you're talking about the LD n ends
going back to the book the LD n ends
came in all varieties of experience and
capability and courage on this operation
we have three very good ones lieutenant
Kwan was a first-rate LDN an officer and
ding and Kwan this other Kwan is an
enlisted Lal DNN no relation were two
guys I'd work with on my first tour and
was with them again in two Enon dang and
Kwan were good to go but the problem was
Kwan the officer well Kwan was hurt and
that's the reason sir yeah the problem
was that lute Winnick lieutenant Kwan he
liked to get after a little bit
sometimes less luck all of us maybe he
had too much to drink the night before
and so he what do you get now some kind
of accident yeah he was riding it and a
whaler ran into the pier he had his head
and he busted both his eyes and he could
have you sees they were both completely
shut so this is how we got the other new
officer which I've never worked with but
uh but I'd worked many tours I mean not
many tours but many operations with the
other two guys and I'd worked with Kwan
and he was really good but of course he
was unable to make the OP so they we
brought in another young officer which I
had never operated with and this other
just so everyone knows as we're going
through this the other officer that you
now brought on that you hadn't worked
with before his name was lieutenant
blonde yeah am I saying that right no
but I'm not gonna really help got the
vietnamese speaker in here tighten me up
so you had the the Navy was out to see
the two things the Navy was supposed to
help you with was helping you guys do
navigation because in this time no GPS
it's so easy now I'm embarrassed by how
yeah this and obviously fire support if
you need it yep basically what they were
supposed to do is vector or sin and
that's where each ship takes the radar
plunge and they shoot it in and they see
where we are in in the jocks
which were 39-foot concrete junks is
what the and then they would see where
we were then they'd shoot us at azmuth
and then we would take our compass and
we'd go in there one of the ships
shooting is they were trying to overtake
Quan tree again and he left and went
down south to help give gunfire support
to the help the Vietnamese Army and
Marine Corps to hold off the NVA
and when that one guy shot the azmuth
and he was about three degrees off but
when you're 15 miles off the beach three
degrees is a lot yeah and everybody said
the CEO said that's the river of rust it
actually was the Ben hai river which was
actually in North Vietnam so when we
went inserted we're way north of the
quad Viet now
you had talked about Bill Woodruff woody
you're referring to him and all as at an
important point here and this is
something we always try to hold true to
you won't always put like a seal with
your assets if you can't manage it so
you got a seal out there on the boats
that are going to be recovering you
because it's a guy that you know it's a
guy that you trust then you know he's
not going to leave you hanging and the
mule is hanging that's right and you
know that's a good lesson learned for
anybody doing operations right now I
don't care what unit you're with if
you're in the Marine Corps and you're
using an army asset try and put a
liaison officer with the army if you're
in the Army you're using a Marine Corps
asset try and put a liaison officer
same thing with Special Operations
because those are the guys that speak
your language they're gonna be able to
predict what you're gonna do if things
are going sideways it's just it's just a
smart move to do and then you know you
talked about how these things started
going wrong and you're you're off the
coast and instead of being where you
thought you were you're at the Ben hai
river which is basically south of the
Ben hai so we and Tommy and I discussed
it and he said we'll go ahead and go in
we'll do what we call a horseshoe off
we'll go in so many clicks and go north
and then go back to the spec to the
ocean and and try to if we can pick up
you know if we could do it we were doing
a body snatch too closely of course by a
body stance you get your best
intelligence that way so then we used to
do direct action missions to go capture
bad guys but we didn't call them body
snatches and I'm kind of wishing we did
it sounds a lot better than just body
snatch you guys should have named those
body snatching operations I would have
felt a lot better about it so it and
tactically you're going in it's pretty
normal you swim in it's pretty normal
you get on the beach and here we go back
to the book this is you talk and I was
carrying the Starlite scope a bulky
first-generation night-vision device
that allowed you to see relatively well
at night it was the size of a loaf of
bread and weighed 8 pounds Tommy told me
to scout the beach area to see if I
could find any of the features we were
looking for or expecting to find like
the mouth of the river
I went north about 200 yards from our
position in the same distance to the
south and with the Starlight scope I
could see a good ways up and down the
beach no River mouth and nothing looked
familiar
Tommy moved inland just a short distance
to look the area over with his
binoculars neither of us saw anything
that indicated we were supposed to be so
and then like you said you you know
you're in the wrong space but you might
as well do in reconnaissance while
you're there and that's kind of the the
decision that's made and I was thinking
about this too so I was thinking you
guys only have five guys and the idea
behind that must have been hey let's
travel light and we can maneuver really
quick and then I got to this list of
what you were carrying here's what Mike
was carrying Mike talking I was the mule
on a recon patrol I carried a car 15
carbine and just over 800 rounds of 556
ammunition along with an assortment of
the Dozen fragmentation CS and smoke
grenades I also had three law rockets
and a starlight scope all of us carried
a medical kit and inflatable UDT over
the head life vests I also had our
silenced weapon a 22 caliber automatic
pistol with a suppressor attached to the
barrel we called it a hush puppy
so now
exactly light for for reconnaissance and
moving I was thinking you guys would try
and stay all slick but that's that's no
joke what you were carrying now as your
patron you start seeing fires and
eventually you see movement
you see bunkers and and Tommy says I
think it's about time we get the heck
out of here you say Roger that sir it's
about zero 300 you got about three hours
of darkness left and you get into a
stream right and start moving towards
the beach wells for three different
reasons one that keeps you low
silhouette we knew that we were within a
battalion of NVA at that period time
then we saw tanks and gun in gun
emplacements so we knew that we were way
north of where we were supposed to be so
by getting in the stream the tide ranges
18 feet over there so the current was
running out so we knew it was going out
to the ocean so we got in there by
keeping our low silhouette in there we
could move a lot faster in the water and
we didn't hopefully we wouldn't bump
into any of the enemy out there which
we're starting to move around at that
time in the morning so now you start
hearing something it's correct and you
know you halt the patrol and you see
what you see is NVA soldiers a bunch of
them it's like an encampment of NVA
soldiers and they and and correct me if
I'm wrong but from their position and
where you had moved to in the stream now
you're looking at them and and as you
move to the water you're gonna be
exposed is that is that the situation
well actually they were in a base camp
type dealing there's a quick reaction
force okay the main force was behind us
of course that's that exposed us kind of
cut off our southern route so to the
north of us which we knew were going
farther north there was that big Lagoon
as the map show and so we would have to
our eastern flank we had the ocean to
the western flank we had the lagoon and
then to the south we had the bad guys
that we knew of and to the north we had
some sand dunes and but we could see
after you pass this one big bunker you
could see nothing but flat Beach so we
feared I'd be our best objective to move
up there and Tommy got on top of this we
thought it was a big sand dune but
actually it was a puzzle as a bunker
built me actually had tunnels down
inside of it so and that's the one that
you did a recon and you found that
bunker yeah I found them I mean he
brought Tommy there Tommy went up there
with the radio learn which was dang and
that gave us you know of course back
then is the radios for PRC seven sevens
lana site which you so yeah yeah and
he's trying to make comms back to woody
and or back to the ship but if needed
the [ __ ] was a Newport News in the USS
Morgan this one says ships were then we
had we finally got woody but woody was
done off the mouth of the quaver yet he
thought you know after he got their
bearings they were a long ways off from
where we were so at this point Quan you
guys are you guys are in that bunker and
Quan comes running back and he says
daiwei Norris with the Starlight scope I
see two men coming down the beach
they're quite a way off but they're
heading our way
mm-hmm so then you seem like you come up
with a plan right there of what you're
gonna do yeah which to me I'm like
thinking well I'll let you brief what
your plan was but you see two bad guys
coming down the beach and your idea is
cool it's time to do our body snatch
that's correct and I figured the officer
which name is unmentioned he was bit he
was a good sigh he's like five nine wait
and strong I mean that [ __ ] guy right
and this is the other Vietnamese or the
Vietnamese officer sir the quantity guy
yeah so I put him down on the beach
because the the high water line and
these guys were walking up and down the
high water line and the other guy was
about a hundred a hundred and fifty a
hundred yards ahead of the the guy who
calls the other guy was walking up in
the sand dunes and I figured we got to
make sure we not came out let the other
guys just walking by cuz he's just
tooling down the low the coast line
looking around and so I said I sent Quan
down with the hush puppy and not Quan
but the officer and I sent him down and
I said I'm on this guy's go walk by us
but when the other guy I'll take him out
and then I had Quan there with me and
Quan after I knocked him out cold and
when the Quan got him he taped him up
and and secured him so two guys are the
two enemy are walking down the beach at
a pretty good distance apart you say
okay I'm gonna get me and Quan will go
get this guy will capture him and then
lieutenant or this Vietnamese lieutenant
you go and get this other guy it's
correct and you said kill him right no I
said if he could take him take him back
I got it but he's right on the shoreline
so the waves were breaking that's making
a lot of turbulence and noise and and
and the other guys up in the sand DIMMs
he's at the high-water line walking
around like that I knew he would be the
last one there but we had to make sure
we took him out for sure right and then
I told the officer he he could go up and
take this guy out or eliminate him or
just make sure he didn't go back to the
village because the villages on down the
beach and he he stood up and you know
lied a mile in in Vietnamese doesn't
mean stop come here he's got an ak-47
the bad guy does he's got a you know a
22 long hush puppy which is about from
here across this room and
you know he's out there like that and
then the guy opened fired on him he's
running back towards Tommy and me and
I'm running past him because I know he's
on his own of the village and as I say
in the book you know they were they have
radios like everybody he did so what
sometimes they would the way they would
send information they'd shoot so many
rounds in the sky and somebody'd answer
back but they changed all the time but
at that period of time he only shot off
two rounds so I hopefully that didn't
mean something bad or good and we got to
the opening of the he went across the
creek the creek bed and he was heading
straight to the entrance to the village
and I dropped down to one knee hit two
shots hit him in in the back he fell
down and the next thing all hell I was
50 to 75 bad guys were chasing us down
and and I was heading back to Tommy and
we got back and I would I move doubt on
the point as the book explained so I let
it go so so when you when you grab or
now you're heading back to Tommy and
that's in that big sort of bunker doomed
yeah yeah and so now all you are
co-located in the big bunker
no actually I'm out on the very point
okay and Tommy was up on top of the mark
god dang and they had taken our the guy
we did capture up there and he was up
there so I move the officer to rear
security and told him if he sees
anything let Tommy go and I put Quan
over on my eastern flank which is the
side of the ocean so I was about fifty
feet ahead of him 50 yards ahead of him
so I could cover I could see everybody
coming in so I was kind of like the
point but I kept Quan over to on the
ocean side if they tried to flank me he
would knock them off then I could see
them Lagoon over here I can see the
lagoon and so I could see everything out
in front of me and now the enemy starts
coming for you came forward and and you
start you know engaging them taking them
down and engaged in and what I do I'd
come up over here I'd roll over and come
up somewhere else I throw a grenade over
here I moved back till another grenade
I'd move forward where the grenade hit
because I had by that time and I gave
him a frost pretences how many people we
had they didn't know we had 12 or 15 or
only didn't Tommy no more shooting from
up there but Tommy was on the radio
trying to get communications and what
Tommy was trying to get communications
from and just to kind of lay this out a
little bit the the ships have been told
hey we might need fire support that's
correct well when you and whenever you
set up fire support for yourself you
always set up what we call pre
designated firing position so hey we you
know you name them whatever you're gonna
name them ABCD 1 2 3 or you give them
girls names whatever car names but yeah
it's real easy to jump on the radio and
say hey fire at position Bravo now and
the you know whatever fire support can
start hitting that so that's great if
you're worried you're supposed to be and
that's the issue
ok so Tommy starts doing its best and
saying hey fire rounds at this pre
designated spot they fire rounds of that
pre designated spot yes I couldn't see
it so they started moving north of that
period of time and they were shooting
smoke in the air and and the fire fight
one for almost almost 3 hours actually 2
hours and 55 minutes and we had
eliminated a lot of these guys and they
start falling back and so there's five
of you that are making like 30 40 50
guys fall back well just four of us
because got it the other guy never just
kind of rounded up it with what and
that's just you're taking good fire
discipline correct one or two rounds of
making good hits making sure what I do I
shoot in the sand about an inch and I'd
see their heads come up then I'd shoot a
about an inch below the sand and I get a
head shot every time say if you tell it
and then you'd roll over you know then
was the grenades you or knowing that we
were getting as you mentioned when a
grenade of course we have a four second
delay in ours and and they're their
grenades that we had
pulled those things before and they gun
would go anywhere from 14 seconds to 28
seconds they don't have good quality
controlling their grenade factories like
we do let's see yeah you you're talking
about that you're sending guys off now
you're you continue to shoot you're
continuing to hold your position you're
you're about halfway through your ammo
at this point and then speaking of these
grenades you're in one of these
positions in boom in comes one of those
grenades to your to your spot what you
do about that
well I yelled grenade and I grabbed it
and threw it back I was going 1,000
2,000 3,000 about time I hit 8,000 the
damn grenade came back over and I'm
going 12,000 13,000 because of course
were you in thousands and I gives you a
good second I threw it back and and the
the grenade went back in fourth five
times and I was at 21,000 22,000 I said
this thing's got to go off and it went
off and I was hit six times in my back
was wrapped now and I just yelled out I
didn't say nothing else and when I
yelled out I just stayed there and I
looked up and there was four guys coming
across and I eliminated all four of
those guys and that's when we found out
they started falling back and Tommy said
they were falling back and I said that's
it he said are you okay I said you know
I'm wounded but I'm okay a week I'm
still very very mobile and of course the
Adrenaline's pumping like god knows what
and and you don't worry about yourself
used to just need you know you need to
get out of there that's all we knew now
at this point it seems like they're
falling back a little bit and it looks
like from from the way it's described
there's basically another dune that's a
little further back from where you are
approximately 500 yards and that's to
the north of the North right by itself I
mean everything else is flat except for
that one doom and so what you what you
guys hash the plan real quick all right
let's get to that thing it's further
away it to create some distance and then
from there we can eventually get in the
water and get
here and you know I talk about cover and
move all the time and and that's like
the fundamental principle of of how we
fight and in in a normal situation you
would just get little terrain features
and you'd move back a little piece at a
time because because that's how you
support each other in this one there was
nowhere to hide in between those two no
so you guys made the call of Tommy and
who's gonna stay up there who's Tommy
and Dangs a real mistake up there and
tommy said you fall back because at that
period of time I was the only one that
had any a been wounded but what we did I
looked across had a pair of binoculars I
looked across and I said I couldn't
understand why because I counted almost
100 guys some Tommy says a lot more than
that and it was a NVA betaine they were
current trying to encircle us and and by
the time I got back as the book says Dan
comes back by himself because Tommy had
been shot in the head at that period of
time so so you guys they put down cover
they put down cover fire for you you're
right and then you fall back you're
doing what you're supposed to do and you
got the Vietnamese lieutenant and you
got Quan with you on you get back to
that position and that means lieutenant
Norris is still up in the big bunker
getting ready he's waiting for your fire
support and and while that's happening
I'm gonna go to the book right here I
was asking for naval gunfire right onto
our position mmm and he says those
rounds could have hit dang and me just
as well as the bad guys but I had no
choice the guy on the radio came back
and said understand fire for effect and
I said absolutely put it on us and he
said are you sure and I said just get it
in here and so they had actually as they
were called in this naval gunfire hmm
Tommy was like seeing guys comin and
like through the grace of God a one big
round hit there and they hit them and
got a lot of bad guys and then again
going back to the book
I went back to getting the law ready to
fire that's a law rocket I could hear
the ship shooting but that's the last
thing I remember
and then the narrator comes in and says
at that point in the fight Tom Norris
took an ak-47 round to the left side of
his forehead the bullet entered his
skull at the orbital socket of his left
eye toward a section of his skull
exposing his brain and caught a shallow
furrow along the brain itself
dang saw his officer go down and the
extent of his head wound his lieutenant
had been shot dead knowing there was
nothing he could do he made for the
others who had just taken a position on
the next dune to the north as he ran he
took a round through the radio he still
carried on his back knocking him down
the round destroyed the radio and saved
his life but fragments carried through
into his back dange picked himself up
and kept running
it took him close to ten minutes to
reach Mike where's Tommy Mike asked dang
when he reached him where is daiwei
daiwei is dead dang replied and this is
it so you know your trusted Vietnamese
fellow
seal says hey look the lieutenant that's
died way lieutenant he's dead and this
is what you do I'm going to the book
here
I told Kwan and the others to wait here
that I was going back for Tommy they
tried to stop me saying it was no use he
was dead I believed them I too thought
he was dead but I wasn't going to leave
him behind we never leave anybody behind
so no way was I going to be the first to
do that and I've been wounded or dead
he'd have come back for me that's who we
are
dang said he was dead and I had no
reason not to believe him it didn't
matter and what if by chance he was
still alive I could not have lived with
myself if I have left him behind not
knowing or what the NVA might do to him
if he were still alive
that whole area south of the bunker was
littered with bodies and they would be
looking for revenge
I had close to a quarter of a mile to
cover and the last part it was uphill
but I ran all the way the initial salvo
from the Morton that was the ship out at
sea although I didn't know it at the
time that it was the Morton shooting had
made the bad guys think twice about
advancing on the dune with the bunker
when I got close
I saw them moving carefully toward the
bunker from where I could see they were
flanking the bunker and moving in from
the east or the beach side as well as
from the south I saw Tommy lying on the
west side of the bunker - guys were
climbing over the top as they moved in
from the east they moved cautiously and
got within a few feet of him I shot them
both and moved to where Tommy was he had
an unbelievable head wound the whole
side of his forehead was gone his brain
was visible you could actually see it
the front lobe of his brain was kind of
pushing out through his skull I could
see why dang said he was dead I sure
thought he was I picked him up put him
over my shoulder and started running I
also grabbed his ak-47 as I knew I was
getting low on ammo I hadn't taken more
than ten steps from the bunker when
there was this explosion behind me from
naval gunfire round the concussion
picked us both up in the air lifting
Tommy off my shoulder and tossed us
forward ten or fifteen feet I literally
saw him move my shoulder leave my
shoulder and fly through the air when I
landed I sat there for a moment stunned
trying to orient myself and catch my
breath
once I sorted myself out I crawled over
to where Tommy was lying in the sand
once I got to Tommy again and started to
pick him up he spoke to me for the first
time he said Mike buddy and that was
when I knew he was alive I said can you
run and he says I can run but I can't
see but he really couldn't run
then he blanked out again I put him in a
fireman's carry and took off for the
dune to the north where I had left the
others I heard him talking now and then
and I guessed he was fading in and out
but I knew he was alive and I put all my
energy and focused to covering the
ground between where we were and the
other dune well like I said you know you
and I've talked about the camaraderie
and the respect we have for each other
and even though Tommy's much smaller
than I am that he would have done the
same thing for me I know that so so just
like you say you you know if he died
which were all honors we understand what
our job more it is as being Navy cells
but I could have never lived with myself
knowing that he was dead I thought he
was dead but the grace of God he's still
with us
so as we I was running back with him I
got shot to my left calf and through my
my left calf and I fell to the ground
and we got back in there's Quan and a
giving us cover fire were you like when
I've done stuff that was maybe not the
safest things in the world I never was
really thinking like oh this is
dangerous were you thinking oh this is
really dangerous oh well you just oh
he's over there and I got to go get him
because that's what we do that's what we
do so that's what it is you don't you
know fear is a good thing but you got to
focus I mean if you know I could have
set dinners today we go all grilled I'm
just go lie here and do it but I said
I'm gonna take as many of those sob down
as I can and you know and then the thing
is is that it it's like we go back to
what we are and in the camaraderie and
going through training or why we do
things and things like that and I think
of the broader was my father as I go
back to I look about it cuz my dad never
would have left me behind or anybody
else behind you know and that's what's
instilled in us as we go through
training and that's what's instilled us
you know no tomboy Hendon was saying
last night he said you know I don't
think you and your what fear was well I
knew what it was but I mean being afraid
you know if you worry about being afraid
of everything you should never be in the
field because you're not focused on what
what you're trying to do so that's the
whole thing is you know so we're out
there to do a job so let's get the damn
job done yet it's interesting to me I
would I think guys would feel more
afraid when we were getting ready to go
in the field when even me you know you
when you have time to think like oh
we're going down this street which has
had you know there's 17 IEDs on it the
last four days and there's guaranteed to
be another one on there tonight what the
question is is it gonna hit yours are
gonna hit someone else and that's I
would see the look on guys
says while we were getting ready to go
out and it you could see a little bit of
that but once you're in the field
everyone's doing what they do they're
just doing their job and I just like
flicking the switch
you know why switch you get you'd get
your mind and know what you're supposed
to be doing so the guys doesn't have his
mind in the game he's gonna stay at home
he ain't going out in the field with my
teeth or not promise you that now this
is one of my one of my favorite parts of
the book that is well I'll read it when
I got this is you talking when I got
back to the Dune dang in-kwon were
waiting for me providing cover fire
lieutenant Tuan was nowhere in sight
he'd already made it for the water to
escape but God bless ding and Quan they
waited for me and were still in the
fight even though dang was wounded they
said Mike what do we do now and I said
we swim which is the classic SEAL
scenario in that the water is our
salvation you know it's like we we have
that special experience in the water and
and people aren't comfortable in the
water and it's our home and that that
was just the classic answer these guys
were said what do we do now remember
we're combat slumbers not combat runners
but the running does help
so now talk about when you're getting
now you're moving to the water you're
carrying Tommy what goes on then well I
didn't inflate Tommy's life jacket as
some of the stories said I I was using
Tommy's like a surfboard and every time
a wave would break I'd push him
underwater and bring him up the other
side because the worst thing you could
do is have a wave and we had six sets of
waves coming in and that's how Quan
ended up getting injured can you guys
shot
and so after I got Tommy out that's when
I put and I could never find Tommy's
lifejacket and he had it in a pocket
down on his calf and I said why so
wonder if I get a bullet hole
I said it's good because we can put a
piece of tape and you know if you have a
you know sucking chest wound I can take
so I took my life check it off me put it
on his head and I took the you know the
old UDT I took a harness but I just put
a little bit of air and I started breast
stroking out to sea and that's when I
saw Kwan was in not going anywhere and I
could see dang out in front of me and so
I swam over and grabbed Kwan and I put
Kwan in front of me
Wan had been shot too he had been shot
he bad you know yeah then the back femur
and also his buttocks was completely
kind of gone so he couldn't so I say
you're wounded you got shrapnel on your
back and he got shot in the leg like you
got lieutenant Norris who's basically
unconscious dying and now you got Kwan
who he can't move himself he's in mobile
as well correct and gang his leading
point as you guys are paddle out and
you're carrying both these other guys
into the water so what I did I took Kwan
and put his arms I'll put my arms
underneath Kwan's arms and he yelled
Tommy like this and I started breast
stroking and two we got out past the
range of their weapons and at that
period of time i inflated coins like
tank with a little bit then i actually
tied his life jacket to my waist and i
towed Kwan and swam with Tommy on my
back here's again a typical I think this
exemplifies that seal attitude right
here this is you talking every time
Tommy woke up it was Mike you got
everyone I could only count four of us
where's the other guy I'd say I got them
I got everyone and then he drift off
again then when he woke up but again it
was Mike you got everyone do you have
all of them and I'd say damn it Tommy I
got them all okay they're accounted for
but I just love the fact that you know
you got a guy that's clearly close to
death and when he does become conscious
his number one concern is does he have
his guys with him his troops
and that's the way great leadership is
sometimes they people surpass that
because they you know but it goes back
to the thing that you and I were talking
about earlier you take care of your
people your people will take care of you
now you get out you know pass like you
said pass the small arms fire and and
again dang and Quan keep asking Mike
what do we do what do we do and each
time you said we swim we just keep
swimming we'll swim south all the way to
to enon if we have to that's correct and
that's what you did you start you kept
swimming and kept swimming and kept
swimming and you're out there for three
hours swimming and and just to put that
into some perspective for people that
have never swam in the open ocean before
the longest swim that you do in seal
training is five point five now nautical
miles which is six point two statute
regular land miles and that takes
depending on the current depending on
how good of your swimmer you are that's
the longest swim that they actually make
you do and that takes like three four
sometimes five hours that's the longest
one that they make you do and by the way
they give you a little water break in
between so here you are swimming this
and you you're wounded shot the leg like
I said you're dragging these other guys
now luckily bill Woodruff and we talked
about this earlier you have a bull he
saved our life I mean Billy wouldn't
give up on us he would not give up he
kept looking for us and they and
actually the Morgan thought they'd
killed us all they thought and they
never knew until several years ago that
we were still whole hi no that's that's
actually a great and again obviously I
can't cover the whole book on the almond
part on this show but get the book
because there's dick couch did a great
job of actually going out and talking to
the people that were that were firing
talking to people on the Morgan and
you're right they they fired rounds and
all of a sudden they didn't hear
anything
and they fired danger close rounds
meaning like
that we know are going to be very close
to our friendly forces and then they
never heard another word so their
thought was you know horrible we must
have hit our own guys and but luckily
and any other thing that's interesting
about Bill Woody Woodruff is the other
lieutenant Vietnamese lieutenant had
actually gotten out to them and told him
hey this is what happened the lieutenant
got killed Mike went to go get him and
never came back
that's what he got told so the word got
back to woody and he called the Newport
News and they went out with the navy
blue that Tommy was dead and I was
missing in action and they were still
looking for Kwan and dying so ok so
here's actually here we here here in the
book and again dick couch did a great
job getting back with all the all the
guys that had were there or at least a
lot of them and he's talking to - woody
here bill Woodruff he says it was about
11:30 and I saw the Newport News begin
to move off to the south then my junk
skipper got a call from the other junk
that was off to the north and slightly
inshore from us we were about a half a
mile apart so as to better search the
area
they said they had swimmers in the water
and we're going to get them you can't
know what that meant so there it is
because bill stuck around and I have the
greatest admiration and respect for Bill
I'm glad that bill found us because
bills will do a counter attack and then
we had Ryan mccumby down in doing on
getting a bunch of guy everybody else
that was left to come and find us so
that goes back to the things about
taking care of your teammates you know
and and and thank God they did find us
because uh none of those guys would have
made it because I mean they had over 600
bad guys up there so they you know you
know sometimes you don't want to leave
nobody behind but sometimes you got to
take your losses too you know
it was the two things and I've heard
this from other seals from Vietnam to
missions there's no question we're
launching on is down pilot and seals in
trouble we're going yep and that's what
those guys that were instilling to me
none were doing they were getting ready
to go out there go home come they were
coming after us you know and I hate to
say it but I figured we'd the lost
everybody trying to get in to get us so
Tom just because like I said I had the
gun in place was I had tanks in there we
weren't the heavy duty guys but that
goes back to even what we have today
with you know like Eric Kristin trying
to go in and losing the guys that you
know we go we're going to go in and get
our boys back out and you know and and
and you know we passed the Pathan on
back from where I am these these young
men who serve us now I have the greatest
admiration they're a lot smarter than I
am because they begin you got these kids
are going through training they'll all
got college education but they're
enlisted guys they just have to be in
the teams and the training they do
that's awesome oh yes way better than
then I had it when I went through there
there and they're very high standards
great guys coming through so you guys
now get back on board but obviously this
isn't over yet because you got severely
wounded especially Tommy Norris and you
you actually told them bring the Newport
News back because there's a correct
there's the doctor I knew there was a
doctor on board because it was a Navy
Cruiser and they had a lieutenant
commander on board and I called woody
and I said we have four WIA and one
critical and and they Newport News did
turn around and we started steaming and
our jock
woody was on the other John our John got
there first and we passed down a boats
and chair then we passed down rigger
than we put Tommy inside that and got
him up there
and I actually picked Tomi up out of it
and carried him down because the thing
was too wide to get through the hatch so
I picked Tomi back up and carried him
down and laid him on the gurney in the
doctor's office and then I got called to
the bridge to debrief the Admiral what
was this is a again a great find by dick
couch another another seal that that
wrote the book another Vietnam seal and
he found a guy named Chuck Zender and
Chuck Zender was a corpsman on the USS
Newport News and I'm not sure why why
dick couch found him or how that worked
but he's the guy that he found and he's
talking about when you guys came on
board and what was interesting was that
a few months before actually a month
earlier they'd had a turret explosion on
the USS Newport News and it killed
eleven killed eleven eleven and wounded
62 hmm and so they these the medical
staff on that was they were kind of
primed luckily they were used to they
had just been through basically a
horrible mass casualty drill and they
were somewhat ready for it which you
know again by the grace of God they were
they had some recent experience with
dealing with wounded and and so that's
why they were ready for this and that's
according to Chuck Zander this this
corpsman and here's here's Chuck Zander
talking when they came aboard they were
pretty scruffy lot my job and handling
casualties was triage I saw them first
evaluated them and sent them on to a
senior medical person corpsman or doctor
for treatment I remember seeing this one
American I couldn't believe his head
wound his forehead was simply blown away
I had two thoughts one it was a good
thing he was in salt water or he'd have
bled to death my second thought was this
man will not be alive in the morning he
went straight to dr. Falchi Rio for tiro
who was waiting for him in surgery there
was this big guy who was with him
and he carried him from the fantail to
the sickbay we had to force him to let
go so we could treat him he wanted to go
into surgery with him so that was you
chosen obviously and he also said that
when when they came out and said hey we
need to check you out and you looked and
he said no the Tommy comes first the
rest of us can wait this is Chuck sender
two talking again while we were treating
the Vietnamese seals I kept my eye on
the big American I finally got him to
sit down so we could look him over I saw
blood on his pant leg and I cut into his
trouser I saw a bullet hole in his leg
my eyes got big and I called another
corpsman over to look at it I said we
better treat that and the seal said
something like yeah whatever he just
didn't seem to care but he did care
about the others and kept asking about
them especially his lieutenant we knew
he was a lieutenant because the other
big American seal said he was he had no
rank insignia on him so again your
number-one priority is your teammates
through it another person so you guys
make it back the ship gets you back to
land
Tommy eventually gets casualty
evacuation to the Philippines
yeah I got on the radio and Ryan
mccumbee and we medevac Tommy off by
helicopter to Danang in Ryne flew down
on a helicopter and he was waiting in
Danang and Ryan stayed with Tommy than
they sent a 141 because we knew we had
our POWs Admiral Stockdale Budd day
people like that out and so all the top
doctors you know neurosurgeons all those
guys were over there because they had
already pulled
in Vietnam with the exception of just
general practitioners and by the time we
got Tommy
through the whole operation got him to
the Philippines to Clarks it was almost
nineteen hours long the medevac than his
operation lasted a 19 and a half hours
his first operation and they stayed in
touch with us but I stayed on board the
new portion used to the following day to
take care of the Vietnamese spoke
English but I spoke pretty I mean I very
I was fluent in Vietnamese and so I
stayed on there until we got them all
patched up this is the doctor talking
major Walter grand
he's the neurosurgeon that they had to
get this guy to get get Tommy Norris to
in the Philippines Perth and he says
when he arrived we took him directly
into the o.r at the time general
military battlefield protocol held that
the patient needed to be needed to be or
should be conscious going into surgery
and I was surprised that someone with
this serious of a head wound would be
conscious and conversant fortunately he
was he was still dressed in his
operational gear which were blue jeans
and a black t-shirt of some kind as I
was conducting my initial examination I
remember that he was conscious but but
just barely
I could tell he'd been through a lot
then he seemed to come more alert and
ask sir can you tell me about my men I
know we got them all off the beach but
can you tell me if they're okay still
then it's it's the team's
now they get done with the surgery that
you're talking about little incredibly
long surgery and here's the doctor
talking again on removing the bandage
and inspecting the wound we talked and I
sensed that he didn't know that he no
longer had a left eye I was reluctant to
tell him as he had endured a great deal
but he was a pretty tough fellow so I
told him that we were unable to save his
left eye he thought about it for a
second
and then said do you think they'll kick
me out of the Navy because of that I
said that I couldn't really answer that
but I took it as a good sign
that he still wanted to be a seal then
the funny part it wasn't the eye as much
as was the loss of the front Lobel part
of his brain that was I actually don't
think that's funny sir I don't think it
is either so when you say that what do
you mean that what was the you saying
hey they're not gonna get you out of
even though you've lost part of your
brain yeah well I think that was a one
of the that we talked about it because
he wanted to stay in he he was already
chosen to be a lieutenant commander at
that period of time and of course he own
medical hold that does get to stop and
but Tommy would have been a great he'd
have been a great Admiral I mean he
really would have done us proud as of
Ryan mccumby too and then a few other
guys who didn't go up to the ranks of to
the top but we've had some great
leadership up there and Erik Olson bill
McRaven gentleman Joe Kernan McGuire the
Burke Allen I mean the way you look it I
watched the team's grow from yes 0:04
was as high as you could go and still
being the team's and now look isn't that
looks like the thing and the guys and I
just amaze me every time I look and read
something or something how much I'm so
proud of each one of these young men and
who serve this great nation of ours yeah
it's amazing again that the the attitude
is just constant and you know I had this
with my guys that got wounded that none
of them wanted to go home they wanted to
just stay yeah they ain't care if they
just had to sit and stay in watch they
want to stay with us in Iraq well you
know I mean how proud all you guys were
when we were there with Admiral Olson
and you guys were receiving your awards
and the Pentagon you know after Mikey
Mansour and and you know you look at the
geyser and job and those guys that you
know of course he lost his life in a
very basic operation and but you know
even though when they they had the
diversity against them they continued to
strive to make their life better well
Ryan job's the classic example he was
blind in both eyes he was telling me he
wanted he was already back in America
and he's on the phone told me can I
please come back to Iraq I want to be
with the platoon yeah yeah and he goes
in gets his college education it has a
beautiful family and he's I remember
there when I was able to put the Purple
Heart on him down then Tommy and I were
there with Admiral Lawson of course I
was that pathetic
where was that was that in the hospital
no no he was at the Pentagon oh okay I
think we had for you guys the Penguins
and then we went down and he gave other
from the team three we gave Colin green
was there yeah yes the task unit bruiser
awards ceremony at the Pentagon yeah we
were all pretty surprised to be there
doing that
yeah but yeah Ryan job so you guys put
the Purple Heart on him that God uh yeah
he had the same attitude that year from
Tommy Norris hey can I stay in can I be
there maybe with the guys how much
longer were you in Vietnam after that
operation mmm that was October 31st and
I came home on a break in November and
then I came home for good and
January so then then everybody left in
March of 73 and woody and rest the guys
they stayed there and they came back
there's no final thing perks he and
woody under Chamberlin and Harry Connor
Cola and all those guys Brad bill
Bradford and stuff so and that was the
last sales of course then we got
involved with Delta pretend you know
with the Cambodia issue and all that
kind of stuff and the Philippines and
stuff like that
you uh you talk about coming home here
I'm going to the book coming back to the
team this time was different from my
first vietnam tour when you were labeled
a one tour wonder which is by the way
still what you get called in in this day
and age you come home from your first
deployment or even from my Thailand tour
at SEAL team one you are not a made man
until after your second combat rotation
it was not so much respect from the team
veterans as many of them had been on
four or five combat rotations it had
more to do with acceptance I was now one
of them when guys like Gary Gallagher
and Walt Gustav 'el and Doc cell came up
to you and said nice job over there or
good work getting your lieutenant back
off that Beach it really meant something
there was also getting to know my kid
who thought I was some stranger which I
was and getting reacquainted with my
wife I've been gone more than I was at
home since we were married and there was
the absence of combat both the worrying
of having to go in the field and in some
ways missing the anticipation of getting
ready to go on an operation and the rush
that comes from combat I looked at all
this as normal for any seal coming home
but it was still an adjustment so you
guys same stuff the guys go through now
Delacorte brewing the same exact stuff
guys go ahead
and our spouses don't get enough credit
for what they do I mean they raise our
kids they families they take home you
know stuff that we should be there to
try to help them with but you know we
have amazing spouses you know in the
teams too and we have a lot better you
know the first day I mentioned my wife
they said where she did the Navy issue
or no they done now we have a whole
different outlook thank God and you know
there are part of our lives and they
shift make it better for all know the
the military want all the military wives
oh yeah what they do yeah they're
raising the kids but they're also fixing
water heaters and you know repair and
plumbing and they're just doing
everything in the house like I said
stuff that that we're supposed to be
doing if we're own home so they had to
put up with all the BS with a man's
taking a car in there trying and hell
I'm not to change all they say you know
don't try to pull that one or revise now
going back to the book this is you
talking I was notified in September that
I would receive the Medal of Honor a lot
goes through your mind when something
like that is going to happen to you you
try and play it down in your mind like
it's no big deal but it really is a big
deal everyone in uniform notice it's a
big deal I felt humbled and undeserving
and I swore that I was not going to
change me well you know Mike thorn has
always been a renegade and probably
always will be a renegade and I wasn't
gonna let it change me and so you know
when I went back to get the medal they
wouldn't let Tommy out of the hospital
so I kidnapped kept him so Tommy was
still recovering from the head and he
was just oh well this is this is what a
year later a year later and Tommy still
I mean he's just going through all this
and all the surgeries and everything
else I mean Tommy you went through
surgeries for six and a half years and
still goes even now so you know it's
unbelievable
I mean
so but they wouldn't let him out of the
hospital go to your ceremony know so I
said hey this is my I said I'll bring
him back you know and they said no I
said well I'm gonna get in trouble when
I take him out so I kept him for four
days but in my hotel never filled his
name and everybody in the world's
looking for it in the Surgeon General of
the Navy which is a three store putting
me on report and I had to go to Admirals
Master does my first one you know Tony
fratty who is the charlie platoon chief
we used to we used to talk about Mike
Thornton and we'd say you know just on
random days we'd say hey you know what
Mike Thornton's doing today whatever
Mike Thornton wants to do today
so you just smuggled him out of the
hospital against orders went to went to
admirals mast you talked a little bit
about the ceremony here going back to
the book we showed up at the White House
for the ceremony then we were all taken
in the Oval Office and I was presented
with the medal I'll never forget
President Nixon saying Mike what can I
do for you and I said well mr. president
you could break this medal in half and
give the other half to this young man
which was Tom Norris you were pointing
to standing behind me because he saved
my life too
so again even even in the end there you
are up you're looking out for your
teammate all right all the way through
we still look out for each other even
today after 46 years never just it's a
job that you never give up well the book
like I said I mean we've covered a
fraction of the book and it gives so
much more detail it goes on to talk
about the rest of your Navy career it
goes on to talk about and and obviously
it talks about Tommy Norris his career
as a as the FBI agent by the way went
into the FBI and was an undercover
operative I mean just unbelievable
unbelievable yep you got to get this
book so that you can get the full
details of what I'm talking about and
you know the last thing I wanted to
greet from the book is the citation from
your Medal of Honor please don't they
can go online and read it but the books
called by Otterbein ladies and gentlemen
and I tell ya I I never felt I deserved
them that'll never fill I would deserve
the medal but you know that I wear that
with the honor of the men and women who
served before me served with me and
serve after me but a lot of people don't
know we've lost to me and eight hundred
fifty-three thousand people this great
nation does enjoy our freedoms today and
that's who we can never forget and
freedom is not free and we must honor
each and every one of them and they all
deserve the medal was given their lives
for this great nation of course Mikey
Mansour like I said before what a great
young man I knew Mikey
and
I feel for all our gold star families
and because I've never knock on wood
I've never lost a child but I've lost a
lot of a lot of clothes great friends
and I know what what part of they're
going through but you know until you
lose to a child of your own that you
gods best you to give it's hard to
people to understand but freedom is not
free this written in blood as you know
Chuck well yeah and you know I can't
even fathom what it's like to lose a
child I know uh you know it's I can't I
can't even fathom and you know when I
hear people throwing the word here all
around you know I always I always say
when I hear a lot of veterans say and
that is the real heroes didn't come home
agree with you but at least we did get
them home and we still continue to try
to get the ones the remains of the ones
home well you know the like I said if
you go and get this book you can you can
read it you can learn a lot about these
operations you can learn a lot about
people and what people are capable of
and what real sacrifice looks like and
you know Mike again
like everyone's gonna want to tell you
and tells you all the time thank you for
the service that you made for our
country but as a seal I want to say
thank you for setting the example that
we followed and as a person and as a
human being thank you for showing us
that we're all capable of more than we
thought and no matter how dire the
circumstances no matter how many enemy
forces are advancing no matter how many
rounds they're firing at you know how
many grenades they throw at you no
matter how big the problems that you
face in life never quit on yourself and
never quit on each other very well put
they're drunk Oh sir I think we've kept
you here long enough well echo I'm sorry
you didn't get a whole lot of speaking
time there buddy now enjoying the list
that's what echo does yeah you get the
lucky job you just sit back and listen
to awesome stories but thanks for coming
on as my honor thank you for what you're
doing and getting the word out to the
public and because it's like I say
freedom is not free ladies and gentlemen
the freedom was written in blood and
please don't take advantage of this you
know give back to the ones that were
given so much and I goes back to what
you and I were talking about - I mean
the the wives the children the
sacrifices they make for their for their
spouses to go overseas and keep this
nation free and what's the organization
that you have now
it's called the Michael Lee Thornton
found issues some that fund we give out
money and I don't give out you know
fifty thousand or a hundred thousand I
give out ten thousand here five thousand
there and
and our met foundation basically or I'll
give out 20,000 you know and just a
couple examples one was a young marine
came back he was a corporal they retired
him
of course it down it takes them be
anywhere from nineteen months to two
years to get into the VA he had these
bad headaches but he'd have enough money
to pay for us his co-payments I write a
check to the MRI to the hospital I wrote
right to check they do an MRI fund found
out he had a brain aneurysm in was able
to say the young man's life another one
and we had a guy in special ops he was
an Air Force Major Intel officer at JSOC
and he was overseas his wife got don't
know swith stage four cancer we put her
in the Duke University I tried to save
her life a friend of mine goes back to
the day when we started cell team six in
along which started JSOC in 1980 he was
our chaplain he was a Catholic chaplain
and he calls me said Mike I hear you had
a great foundation I have a problem I
said what is your problem I do our due
diligence we were able to get their kids
into this backed in this Christian
school which all the kids there raised
from the age of seven to ten or eleven I
can't remember and there's three of them
but they had spent their whole school
time in there yeah but the father causes
the coal payments we say I'd already
built up to a like a hundred seven
thousand dollars with the co-payments I
paid for the kids to wish and wrote a
check which was a little bit over
eighteen thousand dollars you know for
all and put them back in there but at
least say he had a stable platform and
everybody knew what was going on with
the mother
yeah all the teachers knew the kids and
stuff like that and then at that period
of time I go back and I make some phone
calls to some good friends of mine in
New York City and they took care of the
over the hundred and seven thousand
dollar co-payment so I put a bandaid on
the problem and then I try to
other but I mean call for fire support
yeah fire so yeah but I mean I work with
the the Navy SEAL foundation Navy SEAL
Family Foundation the we work with to
keep in our history of the museum was
John Lee does a great job that we do up
at Pebble Beach the Marine Corps law
enforcement foundation which is the
number one foundation in the nation to
give or ninety-nine cents of every
dollar raised and I give 97 cents of
every dollar raised I do have one
administrator I pay further so my wife
and I can travel around and and take
care of that but but there's some great
foundations out there I just tell to
make sure you do your due diligence on
their foundations you just go online and
check them out and they're fair a 4 star
5 star and find out but all the
foundations I work with this gotta give
at least 94 cents of every dollar race
now too helpful for the calls where can
they find your foundation just pull up
the the Matt fund okay online and NDT
yeah fund the the Matt bond or the
Michael e thorne I put my name on it the
buck stops with me is somebody's pouring
fingers they only got one finger to
point I'll take full responsibility of
what I do so as I always have you know
don't do and I have people like Bob
Kerry congressman used to be a knight
medal of honors on my board I have an
admiral on my board I have a two really
great businessmen on my board and I have
supports of people all over the United
States which help support their cause
they said they used to give money to
other foundations but they didn't like
the what the money was being supported
so they give me the and I and like I say
we make sure we take care I mean if like
somebody blows up the engine I was the
engine having a bad month they got laid
off and we pay for their rent but we
write the check to the we don't give it
to the person we give it to the complex
or we give them to the hospital or we
give it to the doctor so that way I know
the money's going where it's supposed to
be going so they can get the take care
of there
my problems well obviously your service
isn't quite over yet you're still
serving and still helping veterans and
seals across the board and once again
sir
thank you for coming on it's been an
honor knowing you it's been an honor
talking to you and I look forward to
talking to you again some well we will
Jocko just keep doing what you're doing
and echo keep them out of trouble yes
sir thank you very much for having me on
thank you all right we just took a
technical break and Mike Thornton has
left the building
you know and went to go do what Mike
Thornton does whatever you want which is
pretty much whatever he wants yeah and
it was awesome obviously come on agree
and when Mike Thornton tells you don't
read my citation you don't read the
citation simple as that
those no factor yes no factor at all
yeah yeah but awesome having them on
obviously and now we want to keep having
people like Mike Thornton on the podcast
yes if somebody wanted to help us have
people on this podcast sure do you have
any suggestions on how they could maybe
lend to that effort no Charles the
support sure oh yeah like basically
that's what I'm saying a way to support
yeah yeah of course here's the way and
support yourself that's kind of thing
you know what's good for the goose is
good you know what I'm saying maybe
origin we're in league with origin as
you put it yes I do put it that way sure
yeah so origin main so origin may main
the state just so to be clear yes
origin Mei Annie oh you mean ever like
you might be like main ma and you know
like the state the main one kind of kind
of which makes sense by the way yeah the
main one totally and so you know a lot
of times like okay we'll take the keys
that's how I first heard of origin by
the way Biggie's like all these keys are
dope checked it you know and of course
you know but that technically is kind of
a matter of opinion
as far as like okay I'm gonna look at
this game like okay no I'm because
someone might like forward more than
Chevy or whatever whatever yeah or the
look especially with the keys like you
know the the subtle difference is kind
of you know it's to each their own kind
of thing yeah I guess you're going just
like full-on fashion realm here I don't
go into attention I'm looking for
functionality you probably could have
guessed that yes so yeah and you look
into it so the functionality part yes
all that of course but when you see made
in America this is like the epitome this
is the that basically the defining
situation so you know you know they'll
be like they made in America but then
you know it's closer or whatever you're
saying stays close but then you say okay
dang those are good shirts you know
where do you get your blanks from or
whatever now all we get them from you
know somewhere other than America kind
of thing know the cotton get the cotton
from America
that's what origin did that actual
cotton yeah well why would you talk
about functionality just kind of FYI
yeah when you have a guy that's making
the geese and therefore it's going to
weave the material to make the keys with
mm-hm he's gonna make material that is
specifically the best to have for Aggie
right that's a situation with origin
that type of commitment yes that's why
we're a league with origin yeah totally
makes sense we're kind of we have that
mindset over on this side it makes sense
well so so yeah origin that that's the
one I'm looking forward to Mikey mmm-hmm
and I'm down four G's by the way mm-hmm
but yeah so I'm looking forward to that
one origin main oh RI GI n ma I and II
mmm-hmm just to be clear just in case
it's not just keys yeah you can get the
hash guards I'm glad yeah and we're
gonna be making everything there yeah
we're gonna be making everything that
everything that I utilize in my life
yeah I'm gonna make
it's like that so you're gonna kind of
come out with almost like a life kit
it's really what it is it's don't use
the Reebok terminology bro that's
reductive yeah this is because the
Reebok calls it like the UFC fight kit
okay but I didn't know not kidding like
the word kit is a University where kid
is a universal word yeah you concur with
right but what did you call it the kid
that's what I called it I guess so
so you can call it's the Brits call it
kit they call their OP dear like their
web gear yeah they call it kit yeah
which means that we also because we have
interoperability with the Brits and with
the Aussies sure
so we also tend to call our gear kit so
yes in fact you are correct if you were
to say I'm gonna make all my kit there
right the answer is yes but there's a
fine line where people might think of
the UFC fight kit which didn't go over
real well when they first came out yeah
and you know we're gonna let that be
their thing for sure as far as it going
well or not going well this one what
would it be kind of like the diss the
unofficial discipline equals freedom kit
how about we just call it gear yeah we
could just call it gear I guess that's
my vote all right I don't rule the world
well so if you want to call it kit on
your side and I'll call it gear over
here yeah let's do that
you know that way you're comfortable I'm
all about everyone being comfortable
with what they're saying technically
it'll be a kit with gear in it okay
there's a traditional use of the word
kit right right that's like hey okay you
got like rival kids yeah I got a
survival kit when I was sitting you know
then it's got a compass and a whistle
and a pair of matches in it what happens
if you use both matches you're in
trouble so that's a survival kit a
whistle you just said whistle yeah yeah
you know when you're a little kid you
get lost in two ways what you supposed
to blow on the whistle for a while
nobody find you no not that I know what
you doing Kawai would you got lost
you just keep heading in one direction
and in Genosha yeah or or up in the
mountains so it's kind of they call it
mauka and Makai mauka is Mountain Makai
is ocean so that's kind of the
directions yeah
otherwise you just keep walking oh
that's a good lesson for life to college
in the mountains one time long story
maybe some other time back to origin
please another time so boom origin main
all made in America rash guards geez all
like it's nuts this is like yeah and by
the way supplements there too yeah
supplements urgent labs yeah yeah so you
can find it all there yeah it's still
and and we are going to make basically
what we're talking about here chocolate
supplements cuz again what do I
specifically want I'm pretty particular
let's make that thing yeah and and then
we go forward the good part about that
is to is you're kind of one of these
guys you can rest assured you're not
gonna have like this these weird extra
things like I don't know you know hair
dye or something like we will not be
selling a hair dye yeah yeah or
something like this so yeah that'll be
good the good stuff for Jemaine calm yes
also support yourself so on it I I'm not
gonna go into my kettlebell situation
again this time actually yesterday I
worked out I didn't do kettlebells I did
I saw somebody tweeted you that was it
was like an article that said that those
little golf yes squats but not don't
baby yeah and and that was a funny
article you know what the title was
called something along the lines of I'm
trying to make remember it exactly it
was 14 ways to avoid being bigger no to
remain a puny little weakling but
actually puny I think no bleep do we've
your word it'll do you yeah so
apparently given number whatever number
that was I'm gonna remain a puny little
dweeb
apparently here's the thing are those
really goblet squats though cuz goblet
squats no I know what you do you do that
you basically do a front squat yeah
double rack double rack yet cuz goblet
is like cuz this is the form of the
shape of God and that's how you hold it
there it is but what if you use like a
huge s kettlebell moving my metcon yeah
that could work in fact I mean respect
to the author that I forget who wrote it
or whatever but it was a real subjective
really yeah you know I think it was more
of a
Shok article kind of yeah you know you
know but if you take penalties I look a
serious directive out there trying to
help people that have skinny knees proud
of them baby look at you anyway I didn't
really like the article on that level
but for a laugh it was good and and
factually here's the deal the
kettlebells are legit
yeah and they are God let's go out there
let's cross religion but here's the
thing there's a good point
hey yeah I'll tell you what you know
we're talking about what you what you
used to you're good now what you're used
to yeah yeah for some reason I hurt like
my wrist or something
yeah or I hurt something and I couldn't
do back squats or front squats so I was
do yeah I was maybe was my shoulder
anyways I was doing goblet squats with
the with my big kettlebell yeah which is
40 kilograms and I I had put on the
schedule of what I was gonna do like 25
it was a bunch of losers I'm at con
scenarios but the first number was 25 it
was 25 20 15
oh the reps yeah yeah those are the rest
25 hurt yeah yeah I was bang because
it's only it's only 88 pounds right that
champion that should be pretty
insignificant
yeah but you really do when you do those
goblet squats yeah you're using your
whole body to keep that thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think I'm used to it and I
think that yeah and I got used to it in
a pretty short period of time yeah
that's what was cool yeah so on it calm
you can get that kind of stuff there if
you want the cool ones
mmm I think and I don't know cuz then
you know I haven't ventured out and I
don't think I ever will venture out to
go see where I can get other kettlebells
from no need really because you can buy
the regular ones or the adult ones and
let's face it man you take enough
pictures of the dope ones for your
Instagram wherever you take pictures for
and you kind of can't go back you can't
mmm keep that invited yourself into a
kettlebell corner exactly right anyway
and you and your social media yeah have
painted yourself into the
yes corner which is not a bad thing
necessarily on a.com slash chuckle
that's where you get these painting
myself into a corner with my social
media I'm gonna wake up every day at
4:30 yeah you got a post-it guess what
the other day I got home at three
o'clock animal or I got I didn't get to
sleep until like 1:30 yeah when I woke
up in the morning I was really tired
yeah and I was you know what am I gonna
do I'm painting in the corner I had to
say hey guys do it I'm I'm going back to
sleep
and I actually went back to sleep I told
everyone - yeah see that's good though
you took accountability though yeah like
that's just lying which I don't support
oh if you did it if I said if I woke up
took a picture of my watch which I've
had people say like I bet you just week
oh did you ever sometimes just wake up
in the morning take a picture you watch
and you go back to sleep no actually I
don't do that yeah it doesn't seem like
you could ever bring yourself to do no
well why would even want it you know
didn't want to do that
it's a horrible scenario it kind of
defeats the purpose yeah the whole
purpose so the other day woke up took a
picture my watch and I was like I gotta
go gotta to bed I'm too freaking tired
I'm so in fact Abed but you didn't post
it no no no you said I said active it
I'm going back to bed god I'm sorry
hold the line for me yeah I dig your
copper for me actually that one time we
got home cover and snooze you guys cover
and get after that would be over here
snoozing well hey that's the freedom
part though yeah then you have the
freedom to a man you gotta sometimes I
mean you can't like um especially if
you're working out and you don't you
straight up don't get enough sleep I'm
not saying you don't you don't but
that's not what I'm saying right now but
if you the proverb you you us when we
don't get enough recovery uh-huh which
sleep is recovery right that's not a
good thing man so every once in a while
you gotta exercise that restraint in the
form of the freedom to sleep in yeah
well I did it's part of life anyway on
it also the whole painting yourself in
the corner okay so I got this jump rope
and it's like you know then I don't know
how up-to-date you are on the new jump
rope
I know they're getting better there
their dough and here's the thing if you
just buy a regular jump rope like you'll
see the difference and I mentioned that
because I got a on it jump rope I told
you about the time my neighbor taught me
I do the crossover tie servers and
that's what it really hit me like this
is the dope jump rope so if you want to
upgrade your jump rope boom on it that's
the one
in fact just go in there see what what
up see what they have there a lot of
good stuff a lot of good stuff
also good way to support when we get
this book by honour-bound Tom Norris
Mike Thornton and dick couch when you
get this book going our website joke
about cast calm there's a book section
top menu boom click on their books from
podcast by episode by the way this
episode 89 click through there I'll take
you to Amazon you get your books there
or even if you can do some other
shopping if you're gonna buy a lawn more
duct tape whatever click through there
good way to support you know small
little action just one little click
through big reaction by way of support
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already iTunes stitcher google
play all these podcasting providing
platforms and YouTube for the video
versions of podcasts and excerpts and
some other various little video things
that's a good way to support also job
where's the store it's called chocolate
or chocolate or calm there are hats
they're good hats trucker hats flex fit
three colors weight flex fit they're
flexing weight they don't have the
little like thing in the back where you
not
yeah the snapback no I think they're
flex fit they don't make trucker hats
that are flex fit I don't think they do
now oh okay pretty sure I'm fairly
positive they're hit with their hats
bass yeah and they're they're dope yeah
I thought you're gonna bring me nine of
them yeah yeah you didn't do that those
that's a bummer
John Bull has a store but Jocko has no
hats there is a you know what there's
this other kind of hat I think it's
called like like an operator hat it's
like real simple anyway I'm about you
know doing that one too interesting in
the event of you not being as into the
trucker hat is
maybe something else we'll see flex it
as well that's my being and is flexpa
cool is that good yeah flex fit has a
purpose I just have never seen a
trucker's hat flex fit yeah and I doubt
I'm gonna see one now
nah man it's the new stuff apparently
but yeah some other stuff on there some
shirts on there cool stuff Jocko even
has a shirt that he designed which is
cool layers if you will just I like the
way you promote the shirt that has your
picture on it you proud of that oh you
know I'm not actually because I didn't
wear that one you know I didn't want I
didn't want my picture on there yeah
actually that's true I got to give you
that echo did not want to have an echo
shirt because it doesn't demand edit
yeah he told it she's called Jacko's
door I got some pole yeah hey Charlie on
store and I'm not saying to buy this
shirt I'm not saying to buy a hat I'm
saying go on the store chocolate or calm
again if you like something get
something good support also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album with tracks
jaco tracks and these tracks help you
get through moments of weakness in your
campaign against weakness every once in
a while when you wage these hard
campaigns against weakness against your
you know waking up early sticking to the
diet workout all this stuff sometimes
you get moments of fatigue sometimes
even the strongest have their moments of
fatigue that's affirmative
so this I called you wore fur these
tracks they're like little spots for
those moments of fatigue get you through
it no problem psychologically then you
act boom so yeah that's a good one so if
you're you know waking up early like I
said you're waking up early you feel
like hitting the snooze listen to
psychological warfare one of those
tracks on there I think it's called get
up and get after it you will not hit the
snooze good one you know that's it
psychological will link anywhere iTunes
where else Amazon music all these place
where they sell mp3's good you can get
him there yeah yeah this book that that
we covered today by Mike Thornton by
Tommy Norris and my dick couch
you can get you gotta get this book it's
a great book it's a great read and
that's a good place to start
so much more detail than I went over
today when we just as I was walking out
Mike and his wife and I was telling her
that I was explaining to him that it's
like the debrief I wanted since I was a
thief or in the Navy
yeah they wanted to know what happened I
wanted the details well now we got him
and those are some crazy details by the
way yeah yeah it's crazy he's deep he's
talking about how yeah you know my
friend gets his like four head blown off
or whatever you can see his brain all
this stuff even in a movie that that'd
be pretty graphic see even in a movie
that be unbelievable yeah lucky bag oh
that movie wasn't really realistic
because the guy had his head blown off
and he lived but that was a crazy part
though right hate on that movie you know
but yeah well it really happened oh so
he's you know he has him his other guy
he's shot by the way
it is like and he's going you know
through the ocean all this stuff and
shrapnel in his back from that he threw
back five times and then we're sitting
here and he sees he's sitting right
there that's the guy who really did that
you know he's not
I mean recent of course acting is cool
in dope furro but that's not an actor
that's a guy who really did it heavy but
that's heavy yeah it's crazy so get the
book read about it read the rest of the
details that we barely even scratched
the surface on also some other books you
can get you need a book called extreme
ownership it's about leadership yeah it
teaches you how to lead sure it's a book
that I wish I had when I was a young
leader mm-hmm but I didn't have it I
wasn't old enough to have written it and
giving it back to myself yet yeah it
doesn't work like that
also we're speaking of being young using
another book called the way of the
warrior kid which is awesome because
kids all over the place like parents now
when I'm speaking somewhere they bring
their kids yeah so I get to meet these
kids yeah kids that are getting after it
which is pretty awesome so way the
warrior kid so many kids are like doing
pull-ups now yes sir
I was just gonna say my thing my
daughter would be like she's bothering
me dad dad I want to do pull-ups she
doesn't want to go you don't get that
from reading Cinderella Cinderella did
not make her want to want to do that
right well right I did tell her the
story Cinderella last night
coincidentally she poops about it don't
know I didn't compel her to go do
anything compel her to eat better no did
it compel her to study hard no she just
said it was beautiful
okay so it compelled some thoughts of
beauty yeah yeah but it didn't compel
any change of direction in life no no
action taken I'm going with way of the
warrior kid yeah me too
also discipline equals free freedom
Field Manual mm-hmm
is coming out that could compel you yeah
to get after it
yeah it could I check it out there's no
books like it no and it's like I'm it's
a manual that's a major part yeah you
know how like when you listen you're
like okay you know you kind of get a
feel but there's nothing there's nothing
about the manual it tells you what to do
yeah and it also talks about some faults
better in my head mm-hmm so is
interesting you can get it appreciate it
also origen main you already covered
that which is good that is now us by the
way we're partnered so when you start
your jujitsu journey or if you're on
your jujitsu journey check it out come
and get it if you're on the path of
getting after it
mm-hmm do it with us at origin and also
if you want to partner with us from a
leadership perspective in your business
our business Ashland front leadership
consulting that's what we do me Lafe
Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke info at
Ashkelon front com
don't Google and look for Jocko speaking
mmm because that's going to give you a
speaker's agent that's going to charge
you more money is there something called
like a like a bureau or thinkers Bureau
speakers agent that's all thank you okay
and and there
trying to provide a service they're
trying to get they're trying to connect
speakers with people that need speakers
but we don't need anyone to connect us
with people that need speakers you can
go straight to Ashland front calm well
so that's that also the muster September
14th and 15th in San Diego just to
clarify the first three musters were
based on the same material because we
did it on the west on the east and then
in the center of the country just to
clarify now that now this muster muster
for is a new material so it's different
new approaches new stories it's not sold
out yet but it will be so if you want to
come register now extreme ownership calm
and while you're waiting for the muster
if you have a question for us you can
ask that question on the interwebs we're
there on the Twitter the Instagram and
that's face ebo haha echo is that echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing also
snapchat are you on there I am on there
and I posted a snap so far one snap and
it disappears after 24 hours yes so you
can't I've got I'm still working to
figure out like how I'm supposed to
utilize this thing yeah so we'll
continue working on that one
yeah and that's it that's how you can
get in touch with us and finally to
anybody else that's out there who thinks
maybe you're being overwhelmed or you
think the deck is stacked against you or
you think you can't go on anymore
think about Mike Thornton and remember
that you are capable of so much more
as long as you never give up and keep
getting after it so until next time this
is echo and Jocko out